では よろしくお願いします
で 今日の経典は あの サンユッタニカーヤというテキストからなんです
ものすごい簡単な経典を選びましたので
短い時間でお分かりになると思います
で クンモというタイトルを入れてますけどもね
百九十九番の経典です
ブータプッバ
ン ビッカラウェークンモ カッチャポーサーヤンナ サマヤン アノーナディーティーレ・ゴーチェラ パスートー アホーシー・シンガー
ローティコー ビッカラウェーサーヤンナ サマヤン アノーナディーティーレ・ゴーチェラ パスートー アホーシー
で そのサンユッタニカーヤというあのー
経典の集まりの場合は
このいろいろ小さな小さな項目
仏教の課題項目を あの
いろんな角度から説明する
だから同じ内容はいろんなところでやるんです
で その同じ内容がいろんなところでいろんな角度から説明しています
だから一つの経典聞いて
まあ説明はそれだけだぞというふうに思う必要はないんです
だから人間というのはね
まあ同じものでもまあいろんな表面
方面で評価したり理解したりしますから
あの 必要なポイントをお釈迦様がいろんな方面で説明してあげるんですね
まあそういうことで この経典というのは
あまり読書にならない場合もそういうわけなんですね
だいたいいくつか読んでみると
同じ内容ではないかと
となってくると なんか面白くなくなっちゃうんですよ
しかし まあそういう読書ではないんですから
経典っていうのは ある一人の人に何かお釈迦様を教える
で その人はまた二度とお釈迦様に会うことはできないかもしれませんし
広いインドですからね
ですから その人には一生悟るまで必要な教えを
まあその短い時間であろうが
長い時間であろうが関係なく説明します
その時も その人の教育関係
それから生活関係 仕事
その範囲で説明しないとわからないんですよ
ですから ある人が何か聞いたら
その人の教育 知識 社会生活
諸関係の中で まあまとめてすべて教えてあげる
で あまり長いことを覚えられない人だったら短く教える
かなり詳しく分析するバラモン系の知識人系の人だったら
かなり詳しく分析してあげたりもします
で そういうのを経典として
お釈迦様はあちらでこういうことを言いました
こちらでこういうことを言いました
あの国でこういうことを言いました
この人にこういうこと言いますとまとめているだけです
それで我々は読書みたいな感じで
では読んでやれそうと思っても
大体同じものが まあ繰り返してくるんですね
それで 一つのことについてでも
だから涅槃のために 悟るための教えですからね
だからバラモン人が質問をすると
そのバラモン人には悟るまでの説明してあげるし
もう牛だけ まあ牛二頭ぐらいだけ飼って
それで生計を立ててるすごい貧しい貧乏な人が来て
もう教育 学問というのはもうもう聞いたことがない
その人も悟り 涅槃に至るまで教えてあげます
だから その人にする説明とバラモン人にする説明の仕方が
アプローチがそれぞれ変わるんですね
しかし 内容は変わらない
内容は変わらないんだから
我々 我々現代人が印刷してテキストを持ってきて
読書で読んでやろうと思ったっていうも
なんか同じ内容ではないかという
そんな問題にはなってくるんですね
ですから こちらで今日言おうとしている内容は
私のこちらでももうもう何回でもね
もう言ったとは思います
ですから 今日初めて聞く内容ではありません
では 説明に入ります ブータプッバンというのは
昔話言う場合はパーリ語で使う言葉ですね
ですから この昔々という風に訳しなくても
訳しなくてもいいんですけど
まあこんなこともありましたよとね
昔はね 別にそれ昔話じゃないんです
今日来るのは こんなことありましたよ
ビッカラウェー比丘たちよ
昔こういうことありました
クンモ カッチャポ クンマというのはサンスクリット語でクールマという言葉で
まあカッチャパはカッチャポ
カッチャポなどという言葉なんですけど
あのカメなんですね カッチャポ・サーヤンナ・サメアン
サーヤンナ・サメアンっていうのは午後
サーヤンナといえば午後
まあやっぱり 何でしたっけ？午後といってもまあ午後のまあ三時過ぎてからみたいなね
まあ四時ぐらいとかね
まあそういうこの後半なんですね
まあ英語で言えばイブニングなんですよ
あ？夕方 アヌ・ナディ・ティーレ
アヌ・ナディ ナディっていうのは川のことで
ナッティーラっていうのは川の
あの まあ川の外なんですけど
まあ川があって そこら辺で
岸の方で ゴーチェラ・パシュトア・アホウシ
ゴーチェラ・パシュト
ゴーチェラっていうのは獲物
食べ物 パシュトっていうのはまあ探して
食べ物を探してアホウシいましたと
夕方 まあカメ一匹はまあそこら辺川から出てきて
そこら辺ちょこちょこ歩いてるんでしょうね
食べるものでもないかなとかね
まあ葉っぱとかいろんなもの食べてるんだからね
次にシンガロ・ピッコ・ビッフレ
で シンガロ シンガロっていうのはこの
まあキツネですけど キツネも種類がいっぱいありますから
このインドの インドのキツネで
それは英語ではジャカールって言うんですけどね
コ・ビッフレ まあキツネも一匹
サーヤンナ・サメアン
夕方 アヌ・ナディ・ティーレ
この川べりのところで
ゴーチェラ・パシュトア・アホウシ
食べ物を探しに まあ出かけていますね
Addeś
ā ko bhikkhave khummo kaccapo siṅgālaṃ dūrato agocarapasaṭtaṃ visvāna sondi
pañcimāni angāni sake kapāle samoditvā appossukko tun
nī bhūto saṅkasāyati. Addeśā
ko bhikkhave khummo kaccapo siṅgālaṃ dūrato agocarapasaṭtaṃ
visvāna sondi pañcimāni
angāni sake kapāle samoditvā appossukko tunnī bhūto saṅkasāyati. それで
アッデサー 見ましたよと
よっていうのはこうでくるんですね
見ましたよと ビッフレ
僕たちを見ましたと 誰ですか
クンモ・カッチャポ このカメさんが見ましたよと
で 何を見たかということを次にくるんです
シンガラン キツネを見ましたと
どんなキツネかと ドゥラトーラ
遠くから 遠く 遠くで来るシンガロを見た
見たと ゴーチェラ・パシュト
普段 あのキツネの餌探しているのは遠くから見て見てしまった
見ましたよと 近視ではなくてよかったね
で 結構遠く見えた 見てしまったんですね
ディスワーナ 見てから
ソンダパンチマーニアンガーニ
ソンダパンチマ ま これはソンディパンチマーニと書いてます
それは発音でそうなりますけど
分解するとソンダパンチマーニとなります
サンディっていうのは本当は雑談に使う言葉なんですけど
鼻のことなんですけど
この場合は首のことでしょうね
パンチマーニパンチャっていうのは 5つ
アンガーニっていうのは何ですかってパーツ部分ですね
だから自分のこのまあ手足やら何て言いますか
まあ手足などなど この 5つの肢をね
まあ頭とあの足 4本ですね
まあその体のこの5体をあのソンダパンチマーニ
ソンダがまあ首のところが 5つに 5番目になる
5つの部位をアンガーにアンガをサケーカパーレ
サケー自分の カパーレっていうのは甲羅
自分の甲羅の中にサモーダヒットワ
よく整えてまとめて自分の甲羅の中にきちんと畳んでおいて
サモーダヒットワといえば
すごく丁寧にきちんと中に畳んでおく
畳んでおいてアッパッスッコ
アッパッスッコというのはじーっとしてじーっとしていることですね
もう頑張ろうとかイライラするとかね
まあもうそういうこと気持ちはなくて
結構落ち着いて まあコスッコというのはあまり努力しないっていう意味なんですね
それで激しく活動してやるぞってことではなくて
落ち着いて ウニーブートっていうのは
まあカメには関係ないんですけど
黙ってることなんですね
サンカサーヤティ サンカサーヤティっていうのは
まあもうこれはなんか様子をじーっと
本当はチェックしながらじーっと黙っている
堂々とあの黙ってるわけ
寝てるわけじゃないんですね
本当はやべえぞっていうことがね
ずーっとありつつも 注意深く隠れていることね
サンカサーヤティというのは
身を隠しているんですね
注意深く シガーローティビッキャヴェーアッダサクンマンカッチャパンドゥラトーワ
まあ抜けてます あのドゥラトーワゴーチェラパスタンという言葉は言えないと
まあなくていいんですけど
シガーローピビッキャヴェーアッダサクンマンカッチャパンドゥラトーワゴーチェラパスタン
ディスワーナイエナクンモカッチャポーテーナウパサンカミ
ウパサンカミットワクンマンカッチャパンパッチュパッティトーワホーシ
それでシガーローピ このシガーラも
シガーラっていうのはキツネも比丘たちをアッデサ見ました
クンマンカッチャパンドゥラトーワゴーチェラパスタンということで
で この何を見たかというと
クンマンカッチャパン
カメを見ました キツネのカメを見ました
まあ外へ遠くから 互いに目がいいみたいですね
遠く見たんです ああ もうカメも外へ出て
餌探しに出ているんだなと
ディスワーナ 見てから
キツネは何をしたんですか？イエナクンモカッチャポーテーナウパサンカミ
イエナどこにクンマあのカメがいるんですか？テーナそこにウパサンカミ
もう近寄ってしまった
近寄りました カメがいるところに行ってしまった
ウパサンカミットワ 近寄ってからですね
ウパサンカミットワ 近寄ってから
クンマンカッチャパンパッチュパッティと
クンマンカッチャパンというのは 2つの言葉も一言葉でカメと
日本語ではカメなんですね
で クンマンカッチャパン・パッチュパッティト・アホティ
パッチュパッティトっていうのはまあそばに様子を見ながらいること
それはその場でその場でパーリ語の意味が変わります
そのその脈絡によって
パッチュパッティタっていうのはいろんな意味がある言葉なんですけど
だいたい人のお世話するために側に立っていることをパッチュパッティタなんですね
例えば大きな晩餐会みたいなものがあったり
すごい あの 何て言いますか
高級レストランで食事をする時とかね
そういうところで誰がそばに待ってるんですね
何か用を仕置きあげようとかね
そんな感じでいることはパッチュパッティタということなんですね
それからまた別の意味もあります
何か思い浮かんだとかね
今はその意味でよく使わないんですね
で 誰かのことを期待してか
もうそういう感じで待つことはパッチュパッティタなの
とにかく ただ関係なく側にこの公園のベンチで私が座ってるともう一人の人が座ってるけど
それはパッチュパッティタじゃないです
側に座ってたっても そちらとこちらは全然関係ないんだから
でも公園で子供が遊んでると
母親もそこら辺でベンチに座っている場合はパッチュパッティタなんですね
様子を見ながら 何かあったら手を出すために待ってるんだからね
そこはパッチュパッティタということで
それで亀は あ 亀じゃなくてキツネは
あの亀のところにそばに行って待ってるんです
様子を見ながら そこでキツネの考え方次にあります
ヤダアヤン・クンモ・カッチャポ・ソンディパンチマナン・アンガーナン・アンニャタランワ・アンニャタランワ・アンガン・アビミンナーメッサティ・パッテーワナ
ン・ガリッワ・ウッダリッワ・カーディッサーミーティ
まあなんかお世話するために
ボーイさんみたいに待っていたわけじゃないんですね
ヤダアヤン ヤディアヤン
ヤディ もし アヤン・クンモ・カッチャポ
この亀がもしかするとということで
ソンディパンチマーナン・アンガーナン
まあソンディパンチマーナン・アンガーナン
このソンディ まあ首五番目にして
ある自分の五体を 五体の中でアンニャタランワ・アンニャタラン
アンニャタランワ・アンニャタラン
パーリ語で長いんだけど
日本語訳になると短いんです
どちらか この五体の まあどちらでもいいんだから
どちらかはアンガン どちらかの部分をアビミンナーメッサティ
伸ばすならば もしこのクモが
あー亀が自分のこの五つの部品のどちらでもいいんだから伸ばそうとするならばということで
上でその場で なんだいってこいつはそばにいて
ウッダーリとは引っ張ってカービサーにカービサーマーカービサーに食べて食べてやるぞと
じっと待ってるんです
まあキツネも犬ですから
一応それでちゃんと腰をかけてそばに待ってるんです
様子を見ながら待ってるんです
もしできれば犬だから
首でも足でも何でもいいんで
出した途端にパクッと
捕まって食べてやるぞと
それから引っ張れば引っ張っ
ね もう全部中身が出るんだからね
で まあそこまでまだ難しくはないです
ヤダ
チェコビッケウェーコンモカッチェポソンデパンチマナンアンガナンアンニャタランワアンニャタランワアンガンナアビニンナメシアサシガロクンマンマニッビッジャパッカミオータランアレドマノ
ヤダコービッケウェーコンモ
文章は長いんですけど
ヤダ その時ということで
比丘たちを クンモカッチェポ
亀がソンデパンチマナンアンガナン
自分の五つのソンデパンチマナンアンガナン
五つの えーと まあ部品のアンニュタランワアンニュタラン
どちらかでもどちらでも部分アンガンナアビニンナメス
伸ばしません 外へ出しません
亀は全然もう興味なさそうな感じで
じーっとそのままでいるんですね
全然もう手も足も何も首も出しません
そういう風に待ってた
それでアッチャ その時シガロ
キツネはクンマ クンマンマニッビッジャ
クンマンマっていうのはこの亀からニッビッジャっていうのは諦めてって
いわゆるもう亀のことを諦めた
もうこれで夜になっちゃうし
もう食べ物がなくなっちゃうし
じゃあこれ諦めましょうと
今日はもう晩御飯にクモの肉は食べられないんだから
そういうことで ニッビッジャっていうのは諦めてパッカーン出て行きました
それからオータランアレドマノ
オータランっていうのはこのチャンスというかね
攻撃できる隙間ですね
オータラン 隙間がアレドマノ
もらえなかった 隙間に出会わなかった
なんか弱い瞬間をね 失敗する瞬間という隙間がなかったんだから
もう諦めて狐が帰ってしまったと
それでこれが例えで それからお釈迦様の話に入ります
エー
メーウェコービッケウェートゥンメーティマールーパーティマーサタタンサミタムパッチャパッティトーアッテーウェナーマーンイメーサンチャックトーワーオータランラベーヤ
それで省略されています
ジーハートーワーオータランラベーヤン
マナトーワーオータランラベーヤンティ
で まあそれからどこいつでも出てくるところだから省略になっています
エーメーウェコービッケウェー
このように比丘たちよ
エーメーウェっていうのはこのように
ビッケウェーというのは比丘たちよ
トゥンメーティ あなた方にも
そういうこと 誰かが待ってるんですよ
ずっとそばに あの狐みたいに
あなた方のそばにも誰かが待ってるんだよと
ずっと それ誰ですかと
マールーパーティマー
マーラがパーティマーっていうのは悪
もう マーラはマーラで
パーティマーっていうのはもう悪人という風なね
意味なんですけどね 悪しきもの
マーラという悪しきものがずっと待ってるんだと
そばに サタタンサミタン
サタタンサミタンというのは
このずっと待ってることをこの絶えず待ってるんだけど
絶えず待ってるわ もうあのどこかに休む休憩するわけじゃないんです
あれ二十四時間三百六十五日も二十四時間ももうマーラ
悪しきものが営業中なんです
そばに待ってるんだよと
マーラっていうのはね
やっぱりまあまあ普通は悪魔という言葉で訳しますけど
魔だけでも訳するときもありますけどね
で マーラで覚えた方がね
まあ悪魔と言ったって悪魔という意味でもないし
悪しき者と言ったっても
そういうあのキリスト教みたいに
そういう考え方もあるわけでもないし
ないわけでもないし ちょっと面倒くさい
とにかくマーラがもう二十四時間体制で休憩なしにずっと待ってるんだと
それで比丘たちは お釈迦様の出家している弟子たちはもう亀に例えているんです
その側に座っている狐がもうマーラなんですね
サタタ・サミパン・パッチパッティと
パッチパッティ そばにいるんだと
それで考え方はアッペワ・ナーマ・アハン
こんなことを考える考えることの場合アッペワ・ナーマというのは
それはもうもしかするとできればいいなというね
狙ってるという意味です
何か狙って待ってる場合はアッペワ・ナーマという言葉を使うんですね
アピ・エーワということ
ナーマ・アハン 私はイメーサン
この連中の この人々の
何か部品が出たらすぐ捕まって食べてやるぞという感じで
だから比丘たちのところから何かこの
で 一つ外に出たら もうそこでマーラがパクッと取ってしまうぞということで
マーラがずっと待ってるんだよと
いつでも二十四時間待ってるんだよと
それで比丘は人間だから
亀じゃないんだからね
これ手足を食べようと思ってるわけじゃないんです
比丘の場合は目 耳 鼻 口
体という五つと心という六つなんですね
本当は六つもありまして
亀の場合も尻尾もありますから
で それで種類によりますし
どんな亀にも長い尻尾あるわけじゃないんですけどね
私は子供の頃遊んだ亀たちにはそんなに触れるほど尻尾はなかったんです
でもそこから他の種類
いろいろ別な場所で観察すると
結構尻尾も大きくてありますけどね
それでチャック・トーワ・オータラン・ラベッヤン
ソート・トーワ・オータラン・ラベッヤン
ダーナ・トーワ・オータラン・ラベッヤン
ジューハ・トーワ・オータラン・ラベッヤン
マナ・トーワ・オータラン・ラベッヤン
その六つから何か出す
出すと捕まってやるぞと
それで食べてやるぞとマーラが待ってるんですね
その六つっていうのは
この初めている方々覚えておいた方がいいんですね
もうあの その出家しているお坊さんの六つは
この目 耳 鼻 口 それから体
次に心 その六つ そこを伸ばしちゃうとマーラにまんまと捕まって食べられてしまいます
それでタスマーティヒャ・ビッキャヴェ・インデース・ブッダ・ドゥアーラ・アビヒャレタ
八番目 タスマーティヒ ビクタヴェー インドリエス グッタ ドゥワーラー ヴィハレトゥ
タスマーティヒ だから比丘たちよ
インドリエス この六根に対して
だいたいまあ五根 六根に対して
グッタ・ドゥワーラー
ドア閉めて グッタっていうのはまあ閉める
守るっていうことです
ドゥワーラーっていうのは門ですね
六門を守れと 六門を守ってヴィハレトゥ
生活しなさい で これから仏教の説明に入りますけど
まあこちらでこの比丘たちはこの出家して修行しているんですね
解脱しようと それで修行できなくて
マーラに誘惑されちゃってダメになる可能性もありますね
そこでマーラといえば悪魔やと
なんとかというと もう誰かに外から攻撃されることになったようにはなりますけど
やっぱりこちらでは一つこのリテラルというか
この文学的に まあその概念は使ってるんですね
マーラという概念でね
マーラにやられたんだよと
そこでマーラにやられたっていうのはどういうことかというと
亀の例えで考えると 自分が不注意でちょっと手を出すと前足を出したところで
それで命がなくなったと
あるいはまあちょっとだけ様子見ようと首を出しただけではないかと
まあちょっとだけなんですけど
それでもうもうきつねにもう食べられてしまう
だからこのちょっと不注意になったところでもう終わりだと
そこで人間の場合は この部品というのはもうあの手足ではなくて
目耳鼻というところなんですね
そこでなんでそういう例えを使うかというと
私たちは外と関係を持ってるチャネルはその六つなんですね
そこで私という存在は
この大世界の中で大世界とつながって生活しているんですね
まあ一人でまるっきり一人で独立して生きているわけじゃないんです
で すべてのものとはつながりがあります
ネットワークの中にいるんです
その自分という人が この世界というネットワークにどうやってつなげているかというと
六つのチャネルで繋げているんです
そこで私と世界との関係っていうのは
この六つで成り立ってるんですね
目耳鼻で 眼耳鼻舌身意というね
目耳鼻舌体と心 で 外の世界と繋がっています
それはどういう だからネットワークだから
私が知ってるものっていうのは
すべてこの六つから入る情報なんですね
私が何か知ってるんだぞと言ったっても
この門六つありますから
その門六つから情報が入る
この門六つから宇宙のすべての真理が入るかというと
そんなことじゃないんです
よくよく見ると 目から入る情報っていうのは随分単純明快で
色形しか目から入れませんし
耳から音しか入れませんし
鼻から香りしか入りませんし
体から感覚で触れる感覚しか入れませんし
で 意っていうのは心ですから
心っていうのはその入った情報について考えてるだけの妄想してるだけだから
まあそんなどうったことはないんですね
それは 思考は まあとにかく人間っていうのはこの宇宙を知ってるんだとか何言っても
仏教から見れば 私たちはこの外の世界
それだけで宇宙とかなんとか言う必要はないんです
私がいて 私の外の世界がある
それで私はその外の世界とネットワークで繋げてるんです
私が知ってるコンピューターネットワークっていうのはたった一本で繋げてるんですけど
体の場合は六本でネットワークに繋げているんです
インターネットで一本で繋げてあれほど情報入るんだけど
体には六本繋がってたってそんな大した情報入らないんです
まああの今のインターネットにしたっても
情報っていうのは密じゃないでしょ
聞こえるものと見るものしか入りませんからね
音と見るもの その中でも音はそんなたくさんないし
まあ見るものでしょう
この六つのあの目耳鼻というね
六つのチャネルで外の世界に繋がっている
そこで問題は 私に悩みがあるんだ
苦しみがあるんだ 云々云々ということはね
なんで生まれるかと それで私と言ったっても
私って言ってもいるんでしょうかね
結局この六つのチャネルから情報を入れ替わってるだけのことでしょうに
こちらはネットワークの一部だから端末だから
端末に情報が入って また流して情報が入って
それだけのことなんです
この生命っていうか 自分は一つの端末で
それで外から入る情報があって
それを処理したりしなかったり
また出したりする 出す場合はもう口で出すか
もう喋るか もう手で書いて見せるか
それぐらいしか出す方法はそんなたくさんないんですね
ほとんど喋るぐらいですからね
例えば自分が得た情報を外へ出す場合は
喋るか書くか それしか他人に連絡する方法はない
体でもできるんじゃないか
体でも笑ったり怒ったりするぐらいで
あるいはぶん殴ったりするぐらいしかできませんしね
例えば情報が入った 入ったところでこちら処理するとすごい怒りが生まれたと
前にいる人はぶん殴っちゃうとかね
それも合ってるかないか
その人のせいで起こったかって調べないんですね
例えば前から別な情報入り込んじゃって混乱状態でいる
そこでこの人は何か関係ない
何か別なことを言うと
その人に対して怒ってしまっちゃう
それでその人を殴ったりする
でも 実際にその人が原因で起こったなら
その人を殴ったってしょうがないんですけど
我々はそこまでを調べようともしない
だから体で表現できるぐらいっていうのはそんなもんでね
笑うか怒った顔を見せるか
殴るかぐらいのことで
で あるいは料理の本を読んでみて
ではその料理作りましょうと手足を動かしちゃう
で 大体たくさん情報っていうのは
人間っていうのは手で書いてみせるか
口でしゃべるかっていう２つしか外へ
アウトプットチャネルはそれしかない
インプットチャネルは 6つありますね
そこで私というものはそんなもんで
そんな大胆な大それたものではないし
理解しにくいものでもないんですよ
人間が妄想していた偉大なる生命とやらね
みんな仏様ではないかとか
なんだか訳の分からないことを言ってるだけで
それは明らかに妄想しか何ものもないんですよ
みんな仏性を持ってるんだそうそう
みんな如来仏様であるそうとかね
みんな神の子であるんだそうとかね
だからね まあだから結局もう人間っていうのは大したことないというブッダの立場
この 6つのチャネルからいろいろ入る情報を頭の中で処理して喋ったりする
それだけのことです それでお釈迦様はそこで終わらないで
そんな話はどうでもいいんだから
人間もっと見なさいと自分のことを
あなた方苦しんでるんではないかと
悩んでるんではないかと
怒り憎しみで苦しんでるんではないかと
幸福になりたいんですけど
あまりにも怒りすぎて
あのちっぽけな幸福も圧倒さ
頭の中消えてしまうんではないかと
元気に明るく言おうかなと思って
美味しいものを調べては食べて
調べては食べて 結局はまたひどい病気になって
もう寝たきりになったんではないかと
だからこの一日生きることはね
我々はいかに大変かと
元気で仕事をしたいんだけど
やっぱり自分の感情が入り込んじゃって
なかなか仕事はできない
仕事辞めたら食べるものはない
仕事をしようと思ったところでもう感情が入り込んじゃって仕事はできない
これで生きることは苦しいでしょうし
幸福になりたいんだけど
期待通りにいかない 幸福になるためにやってることは全部幸福をなくしてしまう
そういう風に限りなく苦しんでいる
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬などなど
ものすごいたくさん問題がある
泣きながら生きなく 生きていなくちゃいけない
泣きながら生きるっていうことはどういうことですかと
門と言いながら生きていなくちゃいけない
穏やかということは感じたことはない
安穏ということは感じたことはない
落ちすぎたということはもう感じたことがない
そういう風に人間にはもうものすごい大変生きるということね
これは何なのかと分解してみましょうと
分析してみましょうというのはブッダの道なんですね
そこで分析してみると
いとも簡単に客観的に合理的に分析してみると
発見するのは なんで私が怒るんですかと
神のせいでも悪魔のせいでもないんですね
これは目から耳から入る情報でしょ
この情報を正しく処理しないんだから怒ったんですね
それでこの人間にある問題すべて
この この側で生まれるもんです
目耳鼻から生まれるもんなんです
そういうことをお釈迦様は言いたがっている
だから比丘の側に修行している比丘の側に二十四時間体制で
ずっとマーラが怪しき者が待ってるんだと
手足出したところでもう捕まって食べられてしまうと
だから自分を守る 人も二十四時間体制で自分を守らなくてはいけないんですね
ここで自分を守るといったって
何を守るかというと この六つの門を守ればいいんです
今ネットワークに二十四時間繋げているでしょうに
コンピューターはね だからやっぱりウイルスプロテクション入れておかないと
ファイアウォールというものを入れておかないと
何が入るとわからないんですね
あっちこっちからもう突然の情報が入り込むんだからね
だから私たち人間っていうのは
もう今コンピューターでも機械でも
たとえて言っただけであって
人間っていうのはコンピューターよりも生まれた瞬間からもうこの外の世界にネットワークで繋げているもんだから
やっぱり自分を守るということはどうしても必要なんですね
チャック
ナールーパン・ヴィスワ・ニミッタッガーヒノー・アブワッタ・マヌ・ギャンジャマンガーヒノー・ヤッッター・ヴィカラナン・メナン・チャックン・インドリヤン・
アサン・ワタン・ヴィラランタン・アビンニャー・ドゥーマ・ナッサー・パータカー・プジャラー・ダンマ・アンワッス・レイユン・タッサ・サンガラーヤ・パティパッ
ジャター・ラッカタ・チャックン・インドリヤン・チャックン・インドリヤ・サンガラン・アパッジャター
で チャックナ・ルーパン・ヴィスワ
チャックナ 目で ルーパン
形 見えるものですね 目でルーパン
形を ヴィスワ 見て で 次にマっていうのはいけませんということで
なかれ 言ってはいけませんということで
マ ニミッタッガーヒノー・アブワッタ
ニミッタッガーヒという状態になってはいけませんと
この説明はもう仏教専門的になりますから
説明を受けなくちゃいけない
アブワッタっていうのはなってはならないということでね
ニミッタッガーヒ うん
これはものすごい説明
いいかな ニミッタはそうや
そうですから 予想 想像
得想 うん まあ特徴 特相
特相ですね あの耳 tak っていうのは
特相を取る人になってはいけません
相っていうのは何でしたっけ？人相とか人相とかいう場合の相がありますね
うん そんな感じですけど
特相を取ってはいけないんだと
特ったら特別な特ですか
で 目で見る場合は特相を取ってはいけないんだと
まあそこを一応説明してそこにいきます
で いくらかのね まあ小学生一年生になってくるとね
まあ学校で教えてくれるだろうなと思いますけどね
やっぱり目には犬も猫も入れませんでしょ
象も目の中に入りませんよ
目を開けたら目に入るのは何なのかと
目の中にあるあれ あの情報を受ける連鎖ってすっごい小さいでしょ
それで目の後ろにある何膜でしたっけ？網膜ね
ほんの小さいでしょ その中にそんなどうやらね
宇宙やら映るんですかね
それと話題でもなんでもない
ほんのちょっとの光が入るだけで
でも我々にとっては光ほんのちょっと入って
ちょっと目が刺激するだけのことなんですけど
ボーンとあ 象だ桜の木だ
もう特相を取ってるんですね
だから脳の中でなんかすごいインパクトみたいな刷り込みが起こるんですよ
別に目からそんなもの入ってないんです
自分が寝た瞬間でかなりの大きなインパクトを刷り込みが作ってしまうんです
まあ例えばまあ沖縄で紙にほんのちょっとの穴を開けておく
穴を開けて まあ突然あの中から別にほんのちょっと光が入るだけなんですね
でもその穴に自分の目を当てた時
またすごい世界を見たんです
実際は穴を通るのほんのちょっとの光だけなんですよ
目に来るのはそのちょっとの光だけなんです
だから手にこちら暗い真似事を外に何かあって
小さな穴あって 手を当ててみたら
まあ光ちょっと映るだけでしょう
なんのことないでしょ？不思議でもなんでもない
その手に当たるほんのちょっとの光に目を当ててみたら
突然びっくりがっかりというかね
すごい世界でしょ そこで全ての感情の煩悩が湧いてくるんです
うん で 壁に穴開けて外で手を当ててみると
まあ外の光ほんのほんのちょっと手に映るだけ
何の面白くでもなんでもないんです
これじゃ目に映ったらどうなるんですか
目に当たった 壁の小さな穴からもう外の世界見えてきます
そこで外の世界見たら
自分の子供を誰か殴っているのを見たならば
まあこれで大変なことを起きてしまうんですね
だからそうやって目に入るのはちょっとした情報
光の情報だけ 光だけ それで刺激する
それだけのことなのに
特相をとってはいけない
特相はみんなとってます
それで出家者は修行 修行としてこの特相をとらんことにする
特相をとってはいけないんだと
次の言葉 ナアヌ・ビャンジェナ・ギャアジ
アヌ・ビャンジェナっていうのは
この特相の2番目のこのサッビですね
副相ですね 副相 副相でしたっけ？あの 2
番目という意味ありますでしょ
副大臣とか言うでしょ
うん 副相も取ってはいけないんだと
なんで特相・副相二つにしてたんですかというと
えーと 時々落ちついてる人っていうのはね
まあ別に目に何か入っただけでもね
そんなに驚きはしませんね
というところで あの アッパッすっこうべの亀みたいに別に興味ないような感じでいる
それで あの副相をとってみることをするんですね
例えば野球バットは なんで別に野球バットって面白くないと
何のこともない それで
実はこれはあのヤンキースで
この あの人 名前マックレイが打った
あのホームラン打ったバットですよ
あ なるほど そうですか
同じただのつまらないバットなんですけど
それで手にとって ああそうですかね
さすがだなとかね これで価値観入っちゃって
それからこの後で考えて価値を入れる
入れて離れなくなることは
それは副相から出てくるんです
例えば女の人見たら 見ただけで男の人は別にそんな興味が出てくるわけじゃないんです
それでまあそっちを会ったり喋ったり
いろいろまあ関係持ったり
もう友達になって いろいろもう仲良くしている間で
どんどん毎日同じ人見えるんだから
もう別にもう特相に対してどうしたことはない
よくわかるんです 見ただけでも
でも長い間いろいろまあパーティーを合コンやるわ
まあいろいろどこか遊びに行くわ
いろんなことやってる間にどんどん特相入り始めるんですね
やっぱりあの子は可愛いとかね
親切だとか 優しいとかね
頭がいいとかね いろいろ特相入ってからは
もう恋が もう離れなくなっちゃって
恋が湧いてくるんですね
だから だから特相と副相っていうのは二つにしているんです
人間というのは何でも見ただけでいきなり感情爆発するってことはないんです
それはある時もあります
見ただけで感情爆発しますから
子供にはよくありますね
副相は全然関係ないんです
見ただけでもう驚く驚いてしまうということは
まあまあ それはもう初めて見るんだからね
で その子供 でも例えば何かに興味があって
何かもうおもちゃやら何かにね
それにもうもうおたぶりになってしまったところで
それから副相に出るんですよ
だからカード集めようが何しようか
もうもうプロになってるんですよ
もうもう半年以内に 三ヶ月となってくると
まあこれぐらい種類があるんだぞとかね
まあこれはこれと何が違うの？ここら辺は違いますよとかね
こんな小さなところなんですけど
で そうやってまあ子供の世界を見ても
子供はいろんなコレクションやってますからね
まあいろんな時期でそれ変わりますけど
その時はもう特相ではなくて副相です
初めは特相でびっくりしちゃって
それで仏教 私たち我々にとっては特相・副相取らなきゃ私たちは生きていられないと思ってるんです
こんなのを言ったって怖いんじゃないかとと思うのは
もう苦しみの中で生きていきたいんだからなんです
人をよく区別して もう理解して
物事はできるだけ現象に分けて分けて分けて分けて
これは知識にして あれも知ってる
これも知ってるとかね
それに生まれてくるのは苦しみ悩みだけなんですけど
この苦しみの中で生きていきたい人にとっては
即所復所を取るしか方法はないんですね
だからみんなまあ即所を取るなと言ったら
だったら見たことにならんではないかと文句言うんです
やっぱり即所見から見れば見たことにはならないんですね
はっきり言うと見るなかれっていうぐらいの言葉ですから
お釈迦様そういう単純な言葉言わないだけで明確にさせるだけだから
即所復所を取るなかれと
見るなかれと言ったって意味がないんだからね
なぜならば 即所復所を取る能力は心の働きでしょうし
見なかったらもう本当に見なかったんだから知らないだけであって
心の問題が解決してるわけじゃないんです
もし見たところでまたがっかりする可能性はあります
ですから 即所復所を取らない修行訓練をしてみてください
見るなかれって言わないです
それで人間見る世界はそのままその通りということは全くない
私たちは見たものを頭の中で合成するんだからね
自分で作るんですね 頭の中で
視覚というものを だから見て怒ったと
だいたい人間自分がね
自分が悲しい 悲観的だ
人生うまくいかないんだとかいろいろ言うんですけどね
そんなものよりもどこからそれ生まれたんですかと見た方がやりやすい
なんでそうなったんです？と
すると 見たものと聞いたものだけの話ですよ
ただ何か何か見て 何か何か聞いて
それを合成する 合成する過程で自分が悲観的になってきます
それで悲観的になったら
もう解決方法ないんでしょうか？と聞いたりする
それでみだりにアドバイスしたってもね
カウンセラーがね それは治りっこはない
その代わりに明るく見なさいよで
こういう風に見なさいよとかね
いろいろ別な即所で教えたっても
それは同じことでたまりみたいなものですね
だからこの人間にどんな問題があるって言ったら
見たものか聞いたものっていうのがほとんどです
誰かに殴られて悲観的になったって
それほどはないしね 重体時ぐらいかな
もう殴られたところで自信がなくなったとかね
あるかもしれませんだけどね
で 何かというのは 普通の人の場合は見たものと聞いたもの
ですから 人間は見るものっていうのは
見たんだからその通りっていうことはない
即所復所を取って作って
それを見たとする で だから私が見るものは他の人には見られないし
私が見たんだからといってすごく喧嘩までする
本当に外の世界を見ているならば
誰でも同じ世界を見ているはずなんです
混乱起こらないはずなんです
異論成り立たないはずなんです
ですから 即所復所は取っしないでデータだけ見たらみんな同じなんです
だからこちらで言ってる話は俗世間の話ではなくて
この俗世間を脱却して解脱得るための話なんですね
解脱得るためのためには
この人間持っている感情と概念
主観ではもうできません
それはもう明らかに間違っている
自分が勝手なものを見ているんだと
勝手な幻覚を見ているんです
勝手に作った幻覚 この幻覚作るっていうことは
この特相と複相というね
人間でいえば あの人は綺麗といきなり取るのは特相で
それから鼻が小さくて可愛いとかね
耳がもうちょっともう長くて
それまたすごい可愛いとかね
唇が細くて可愛いとかね
まあ特別にいろいろ 部品部品的に見る
それは特相 とにかくまず言っているのは
特相複相取るなかれと
後から思い出すのも全部複相なんですか
いえいえ でも思い出す時はね
複相の場合はあえて見るんですよ
特相の場合はただ見るだけなんですね
見ただけでわかるところは特相で
あえて見る場合は いろいろ合成しながら
考えながら調べながら
マニュアルを見て参考しながら見る場合はもう複相ですね
次にヤッアーディカラナネタン
ヤッアーディカラナンというのがありますね
チャックインディリアンアサンウタンヴィヒランタンというところ
ヤッアーディカラナンというのはこの
えーと こんなのはね アーディ
次にヤッアーディカラナネタン
ヤッアーディカラナンというのがありますね
チャックインディリアンアサンウタンヴィヒランタンというところ
ヤッアーディカラナンというのはこの
えーと こんなのはね パーリ語的にはすごい厳密に論理的に喋っている使う言葉で
この原因 なぜならばというふうなね
なぜならばというより
このちょっと何故というかというと
ちょっと続く原因をね
語るとき使う言葉ですね
ま とにかくヤッアーディカラナンというのは
まあどういうわけかと
どういう理由かというならばというね
それからどういう原因であるというならばという
皆様はなぜならばと書けばそれだけでいいはずです
チャックインディリアンアサンウタンヴィヒランタン
チャックインディリアン
目という器官 チャックは目
インディリアンというのは器官
目という器官をアサンウタン
制御しないで ヴィヒランタン
生活するとき 目という器官を制御・コントロールしないで生活するときは
なぜならばね 目という器官をコントロール・制御しないで生活するならば
アビッジャー アビッジャーっていうのは余計な欲
まあ粘り強い欲なんですね
なかなか立ちにくい インパクト強いというかね
忘れがたいというか それが刻まれるんですね
よく心の中に ですから余計な欲
ドーマナッサンっていうのは落ち込みですね
いわゆる落ち込み 悲しみというかね
それで見たら思える感情を大きく大雑把に二つに分ける
一つは欲系で もう一つは落ち込み系で
アビッジャーとドーマナッサン
わかりやすい 何か見て楽しいと思うか
楽しくないかね 気持ち悪いと思うかね
嫌だと思うか どちらかなんですね
ですからアビッジャーは欲系のね
余計な欲 ドーマナッサンっていうのはもう悲しみという風に訳するんですけど
これ痛いですね 嫌な気持ちですね
どちらか 落ち込むか楽しむか
その二つの関係あるパータカ
アクシャラダンマ パータカ
不善たる 罪になる アプサラダンマ
不善法 あらゆる不善が悪いことが
アヌワースレイヨン 心の中で次から次へと生まれてくるんだ
心の中にこの染み込むというか
アースラっていうのはこの流れ込むっていう風な
吐き出るっていう意味で
まあ湧き出るでもいいんですね
あらゆる罪が湧いてくるんですね
そこで見ただけのことなんですよ
見ただけのことなんですけど
心の中でものすごくこの新しい湧き水が出たような感じで
次から次へ次から次へとあらゆる感情が湧いてくるんです
その感情は大まかに二つ
二種類ですね 欲系か怒り系か
で そこで明確に あの 仏教の世界っていうのは
このものすごい人間がこの大きく大きく絡まって
複雑に複雑にわけもわからないようにしてる世界っていうのは
ものすごいじーっと単純にするんです
二つ三つにしておくんです
だからもう徹底的に単純化する
それこそ科学なんです
だから人間の世界っていうのは
この猫と糸 毛糸みたいなもんで
もうどっち側にやるんだったみたいに
むちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃになるだけ
だからどんな問題も解決することってのは人間には委託してはいけないんですよ
とにかく混乱の混乱の中にあるから
さらに混乱する 例えば
どんな問題でも人に話させてみてください
ディスカッションさせてみてください
解決法くるんですかと
むちゃくちゃになるんです
明確になって明確になってシンプルになって
あ ではこうしましょうということには決してならない
何か結論が出るんで こういうこともあって
こういうこと あ どうしようかと
ではみんなで話し合いましょうと話し合いになったところで
見事にもうどうにもならない状態に持っていく
それは人間の思考パターンです
単純にしようとはしないんです
これだったらこうなるぞ
あれだったらこうなるぞ
ではこうではないか ああではないかと
そこで何れでもあんまり問題把握するっていうことはしないんですね
それでこちらでこの精神的な問題って
みんなの訴えてくるかかってくる問題っていうのは見えるでしょ
みんな例えば自分が悲観的であるとかね
社会に馴染めないとかね
で なんとかもう小さい頃からどんなものですよとか
なんとかなるものなんですかとか
そういうふうなことに答えあるわけないんです
そういう人々は別に ただ内なる感情だけなんとかしてくれと
じゃあ問題は解決してはいけませんという態度をとってます
初めから  [咳]子供は勉強はしたがらないときしか子供です
なんとかなるんですかと
学校に行きなさいと言ってくれませんかと
それで十分ですね 母親にしたら
それ以外は言いません
だからそんなのは答えにも何でもないんですよ
誰が？じゃあ君 学校に行きなさいよ
それで行けないんだったら
まあでは何でしょうか
では何でしょうかとか
またさらにさらに複雑にしていきます
あの人の意見 この人の意見
あの心理学者の意見 このテキストに言ってることとかね
それで先生が悪いは言うわ
教育システムが悪いというわ
仲間が悪いというわ 学校そのものが悪いというわ
住んでる地方がね 団地が悪いというわ
いろんなことを言う これで解決しますか？それでディスカッションしたところで
もう団地の周りにいる家庭の子供たちが悪いと
だからその子ももう学校に行く気になってないんだよと
だってどうすればいいんです？団地の他の子供たちを追い出すんですかね
この子のために よくそういう結論作るんですよ
例えば親が小さい時 小さい時
父親が亡くなったと だからこの子はそんなもんになったんだよ
あ そう だったらもう生き返ってもらいなさい
父親を そういう答えです
原因だったら だから私はそういう風に言うんだから
まあ一番悪人になってます
それで私は悪人士視化されていることは嫌です
それすごい喜んでるんです
どうせあんた方は悪い子はないんだと
だから小さい時から片親で育てられたんだから
こうなったああなったとか
でたらめもインチキも言いたい放題言って
でたらめインチキ思考でね
幸福な生き方ができるわけないでしょうに
だから物事は科学的に分析しなくちゃいけない
我々もその子供であろうが
どんなバカであろうが
目耳鼻で生きてるんだから
それ言うと話つまらないとかね
この坊主は関係ないことを言うんだと
私は片親に育てられたんだから
自信がないだけではないかと
そんなこと言われても
私にも親を作ってくれって言ってるんですかね
三十五 三十八とか四十二歳の人が
だから自分のバカらしさにですね
気付かねぇ 相手に当たってるのに
それで仏教の世界はもう科学的にきちんと分析をする
誰であろうとも 片親か両親か
親が四人で育てたか そんな話は関係ないと
誰でも目と耳鼻とかそこら辺で生きてるんだよと
そこら辺から情報取ってるんだよと
そこでこの得想 触想を取るところが問題ですよ
得想 触想を取ると 怒り系になるか
欲系になるか それからあらゆる感情が
それから不善たる感情が湧いてくる
それは内の中の問題なんです
外の問題じゃないんです
得想 触想を取った時点でもうガードは切れちゃったでしょうに
それで心の中でずっともう怒り系か欲系の
限りない不善が現れてくる
人間がこの限りない不善は知っている
不善は知らない 結果知っている
うまくいってないんだと
結果だけ知ってる うまく仕事をできないんだと
会社の仲間とうまく馴染めないんだと
それなんとか それ結果でしょうに
馴染めないことだけ問題だったら
まあ道化師みたいなね
なんかお化粧でもして会社に行ってね
毎日毎日何かあのひときどきあのギャグというんですか
何かやっちゃえばね 人気も出ますからね
単純ですよ だからまあ結局はまあそういうことを言ったっても意味がないんです
いろいろ小道具たくさん作って用意して
月曜日は何をするか 火曜日何をするかと
やるとまあまあ二日三日になってくると
もう結構もう馴染めるから
そこで会社に馴染めない
学校に馴染めない 仲間が馴染めないとか
そういう結果だけよ その結果が自分の心の中の不全から
悪から生まれてくる結果なんですね
限りなく悪の思考が湧いているんですよ
なんで限りなく悪の思考が湧いたかというと
見たもの聞いたものに対しては
自分が即座 即座を取って
もう怒り系か欲系の感情を刷り込んでしまってる
だから刷り込みだから
これはもう大変な問題なんですね
自分の心の刷り込み現象は問題であると
それで欲系の感情が現れたら
もういろんな問題が来る
そのものに依存する 自分のものにしようとする
あるいは遊びにふける
学校に行かないでゲームセンターに行く
会社に行かないで飲み屋さんに行く
パチンコに行くとかね
怒り系になってくると
どんどん落ち込む 引っ込む
突然爆発して人を殴ったり刺したり
殺したり刺したりする
通り魔になったりする
あるいは誰とも馴染めなくなっちゃって
みんなにも無視されるようなことになったりとかする
それは怒り系の問題です
そこで人間というのは
五分五分で怒り系も欲系も作ってるんだったら
それでいくらかバランス取っているんだというだけで
でも仏教から見れば病気そのものなんです
怒り系の欲も欲系の欲も
まあほとんどほぼ同じだったらね
ほぼとは言わないんですけど
多少偏ってますけど まあそれなりにたくさんあるんだったら普通の人です
それがあまり激しく偏ると変な人と言うんですね
遊びにふけることに偏っちゃうと
賭け事やらパチンコやら飲む酒飲むことやらね
遊ぶこと そういうものばっかりやって
もう大破産すると あの人はおかしいと
変やと言うだけで 怒り系になって犯罪までに行くと
もう変やと言うんであって
それだけ直そうとする
で 両方持っていると普通の人です
そこでアドバイス来るのは
この両方の問題を持ってる人々からなんですね
だから決して答えが出てこない
いい例っていうのは 例えば世界平和のためにみんなが叫ぶアドバイスをする
でも一つも上手くいかない
上手くいくはずがないんですね
誰一人も平和的じゃないんだから
誰でも弱い者は殺すべきですよと立場を取っている
だからまあ平和主義者はいない
それで平和主義運動をやってる人の話は絶対違う
一般人の考え方とは違いますと政治家が自分で決める
だから精神患者たちに支配されている世界ですからね
一度この地球の問題 一つも解決するわけじゃないんです
そこで宗教の話したって
これまた明確に精神患者たちが集まるんです
超能力やら色々秘湯やら
もういろんなことでどこを走ったってももう道がない
まあそれで答えを持ってるのはただ一つブッダだけなんです
こういう風に分析っていうのは仏教以外はありません
仏教って言ったってブッダの教え以外はありません
ブッダから仏教を脱線したところで
どこを脱線したかというと
また病気の方をへ脱線してしまったんですね
まあ脱線だからね どうしても意味がない
だから堂々とブッダがやるなかれということをやってもいいと
やりましょうと言ったことをやらなくてもいいと
どういうことになっちゃった？修行しなそれはしなくてもいい
煩悩はそれをなくさなくてもいい
なぜならお釈迦様は修行しなさいと言ったでしょう
それはいりません みんなブッダだから
煩悩はなくしいい なくす必要ない
もともとブッダですから
煩悩あってブッダですよ
そこですごいな 素晴らしい教えだなと
またもう他の患者さんたちが言う
だから目が見えない連中を集めて
これこそ世界一綺麗なものやと
ああ そうですね あんたの恋も綺麗だから
やっぱりこれは世界一綺麗なものやと言ったっても
目が見える人にとっては何の関係もないんです
こちらでそのシステムをたったほんのちょっとの言葉でお釈迦様が教えてるんです
目からもう単純つまらない
ほんのちょっとの光のデータが入るだけで
それで瞬時に特徴を複層取ってしまって
これが桜の花だ それから綺麗やと
それからじーっと見る
それでさらに欲が生まれてくる
やっぱり見るだけで楽しくないんだから
じゃあ酒でも持ってこようと
それで酒飲みながら見る
やっぱり酒飲んだけ面白くない
もう何か食べよう 食べながら酒飲みながら
やっぱりそれ面白くて
じゃあ踊りましょうと
そうやってどんどん大きくなっていって
結局花見じゃないんでしょ
これ汚しちゃって 汚くなっちゃって
花一本も見てない やがてそこでもうそれまた面白くない
それでネクタイを捨てて
シャツを脱げて脱いで
それでズボンを下ろして
公の場でサルみたいに木を登るわ
それで警察の車が出て
あまりにもふざけるとまた捕まって
もう正気になるまでもう抑えておかなくちゃいけない
それで夜家に帰る 花見をしましたと
何跡あり？夜か次の日
警察にとっちゃったら次の日ですか
出せます で 結局花見もしてないことでしょ
それで苦しんだだけで
ではどこでスタートするか
そこはどんどん毎回同じことやっちゃうと
この人は変だと ちょっと根性しなくちゃあかんとか
これ何とかしてくれませんかと
言ったっても お守りを高いね 1,000万円や10万円やってて歩くしかないんで
それだったら うるさい
解決法ないんだから ではお守り作ってあげる
それだったら はぁわかります
簡単単純でしょ お守り首にぶら下げてると
そこで心の問題直ると
御札があれば だから火事もを守る御札とかあるんでしょ
あえてその家は火事になるし
事故を起こしてるどんな車でも調べてみてください
必ずしも交通安全のお守りがあるんです
それで私は今交通安全守りがぶら下がっているだと
その車にだけは乗るなよ
心配だ まあ乗ったことはありますけど
降りるまで文句言ってるわけです
すごい精神不安定な状態なんです
運転する人 あるいはこれと言って言っていて
何のためかというと 安全運転のために
それでかなりいろんなことで混乱しちゃって
もうこれやべえと それで気をつけるんです
ある人と二 三回運転してもらったことあるんですけど
ちょっと落ち着いてると
こいつはもう前にこの車近寄ってるのに
そのままスピードを下げず
そのままです これ後ろから行ってぶつけたらね
それで運転でジョッとジョッと行ったら
それがやっぱり運転する人に横から運転のアドバイスするのすごい
それはやっちゃいけないことなんです
運転できなくなるんです
これを馬鹿者 途中で寝ちゃうとどうすることもないんだと
もうもう周りは見ないわ
信号は見ないわ もう何やこれとかね
で見たら もういっぱいあるんじゃないですかね
お守りは それでまるっきり関係ない別の話に始めてね
けなしたい放題でなくて
まあそれでまあもう私のことはいいじゃないかと怒ったかもしれませんけど
私は耳を守って終わったんだからね
言いたいこと言う その場合
確実に自分を起こしちゃうんで
そういう人たちというのは
だから自分の責任自分で持てばいいでしょ
なんでこうとワンセンゴクダイに入るんですかね
だからこの無限大簡単な解決方法っていうのがあったら
ここはまるっきり道が違う
これ科学的に具体的に見なきゃダメです
科学 お釈迦様の科学っていうのは
物事を複雑にするんじゃなくて
徹底的にシンプルにすることなんです
それで私って何やと言ったっても
もう私っているのかという疑問まで出てるよ
ただのネットワークで
そのチャネルで情報入るだけ
その情報すごいことかと
どんだけ単純なことでも
ちょっとした穴から光入るだけです
だったらそこであんたトラブル作ってるんだと心体の中です
だからまず比丘たちに言ってることは
この在家の人に言ってることではないんですけど
特相と複相を取ることがなさい
なぜならばそれで そういうことで
怒り系と欲系の感情が刷り込まれて
それからずっと吹き出てくるんです
あらゆる感情が これコントロールできなくなっちゃうんです
だから最初のところでガードしちゃおうかなと
怒り系と欲系の基本的なことを生まれないところでガードしておくと
心は綺麗な心 綺麗なままになるんです
システムはそれだけです
目で物を見ても 特相 複相
特相 複相を取らないようにする
すごく冷静に 欲も怒りも作れないようにする
それで落ち込みも何もなくなっちゃって
実存の出会い それは何時間でよろしいですかね
が問題ですね 目がある限りそのガードやらなきゃいけないんですね
で 次のこと タッササンワラーヤ・パティパッジョタ
タッササンワラーヤっていうのはこの目のね
それのサンワラーヤ コントロールするためにパティパッジョで頑張ってくださいよ
この経典にはっきりとこうやりなさい
こうやりなさいとはっきり言ってるところ
これは比丘たちにこの戒律を教えていると
ここは戒律です 仏教では
だからこういう風にやりなさいと
目を守りなさいと 目の守り方は見ないでいることではありません
特相 複相を取らないでいること
特相 複相なぜ取らないかというと
欲か怒りが生まれないようにと
欲か怒りが最初は卓球してない
単純に欲が怒りがですよ
それからもっともっと感情がついてきて
ついてきて 湧いてきて
いろんなことになるんです
ひどい目に遭うんですね
後から 妄想過程です 合成過程です
時間経てば経つほど また感情が違うんですね
ちょっとすごい綺麗な人に見て会って
ちょっと話 ちょっと挨拶して話し合って
それで凄い気分が良くなっちゃって
もう帰ったんですけど
後からふと考えたりして
電話番号を聞いて聞けばよかったとかね
それからまた別な別な感情がついてきます
なんで聞かなかった？やっぱり俺って自信がなかったんだからとかね
もうちょっと自信持てばよかったのにとか
それから欲系に行くか怒り系に行くか
その人の性格によって
時間経てば経つほど 問題はどんどんどんどん
なんのちょっと人に会っただけのことで
後からどうなるかわからない
それはもう最初からガードしていないんだからなんです
このようにほか他の機根にも行きます
次にあるのは耳ですね
ソテーナサッダンサットワというところ
ラッカタ また読めなかったところ
ラッカタチャックンイリアン
メットという機根をラッカタ守りなさい
チャックンイレアサンワランアパッジャタ
メットという機根を制御するように始めなさい
意味が同じ意味で目を守りなさい
次に耳を守りなさい 耳に入るのはただの音なんですよ
音の信号というのは マイクロフォンでも拾えるもんでしょ
人の音を聞いてものすごい感情を作るんですけど
同じ音を聞くマイクロフォン何もないでしょうに
マイクロフォンはただの音の信号だけ
で 我々は特徴をとる それは人間の声
女の人の声 有名な歌手の声とかね
友達の声 子供の声 私の子供の声
あれこれやとか 特徴をとる
それからもう もう救いはない
もう終わり 人生 怒りとか欲が生まれて
それからどんどん妄想してひどい目に遭う
だから音は入ったところでガードしておく
次に鼻ですね ガハナ ガハネナガンダンカーイットガハイットワ
鼻から香りを入れる どうってことはないんですよ
ただのどんなものにも匂いっていうものあります
紙にもこの紙にも匂いがあって
絨毯にも匂いがある 壁にも匂いがある
花にも匂いがある 土にも匂いがある
匂いがないものはないんです
ただそれだけで どんな物質も匂いを持っている
その中で一部だけ人間感じる
全部感じます もっと匂いたくさんあります
例えば壁の匂いあるんだけど
もうほとんど感じないし
でも犬だったらそこ感じるし
例えばこの本の匂いとこの紙の匂い
別々匂い持ってますけどね
で まあ人間にはわからない
だから人間わかってるのは匂いもほんのちょっとでしょうに
それに過ぎて作る世界っていうのは
特徴を取ったりして 特徴を取ったりして
特徴を取ったりして 次にあるのはジウハエラサンサーイットワ
舌で味を感じて また特徴
複層としちゃうと 怒りというか欲系になってきまして
また感情が湧いて湧いてくる
煩悩 悪が湧いてくる それでカーエーナポッタダンプティットワ
体に何か触れたら それでまた特徴を取って複層を取って
また心の中で怒りや欲が生まれて
それからまたあらゆる煩悩がどんどんどんどん現れてくる
切りがない 六眼にマナサダンマンヴィンニャーヤ
マナサ 心でダンマン 物事をヴィンニャーヤ
知って 心で考えるもの
例えば本を読んだりすると
心で考えたりするんですね
心でいろんなことを考えて
また特徴 複層を取っちゃうと
またひどい目に遭ってしまいますよ
そこで全部それでこのネットワークの六つのチャンネルがあるネットワークの中で
自分がダメージを受けないように
この窓口で特徴 複層を取らないというVSスキャニングを入れておく
ファイアウォールを入れておく
コンピューター用語を使うならば
目やら耳やそちらにちょっとした警備員を入れておく
目に耳に鼻に 得素得素入れるなよと
見るのはいいんですけど
得素得素入れないと別に見ただけで終わっちゃうんです
花見たという感じにならないんです
カッサパ尊者がお釈迦様の3番目の弟子はね
森の中に洞窟があって
そちらにずっと住んでいたんです
釈迦尼入らなかったんです
そこでカッサパ尊者っていうのはもう大弟子で
お釈迦様もかなり期待していた方です
マコーレン尊者とサーリプッタ尊者がまあそれより年上なんですね
お釈迦様と一緒にいるんです
カッサパ尊者はおそらく弟子で下若かったと思います
若かったんですけど 能力は抜群です
しかし すごい謙虚で まああまり大げさな社会のところには入らない
で お釈迦様から他のお坊様方から
このあるお坊さんたちのグループがね
すごいお坊さんだと話を聴いて
で まあどういう人かとね
一度会ってみたいという気持ちもあったんですけどね
そこでとにかく若い坊さんたちがこのグループがこの
まあそこら辺見学に行って
いろいろ道場やらお寺やらというところに行って
この山を登って すごいきついところで
こんなこちらで あのすごい有名なお坊さんが住んでる洞窟だよっていうことで
そちらに入ってみたんですね
入って周りを見て 山があるんだ
川があるんだとかね いろいろ見て
カッサパ長老の尊者の洞窟の中に入ったんですね
入ってあっちこっちを見たら
もう天井っていうのはあまりにも豪快に飾ってるんです
いわゆる天井画ですか
絵を描いてるんです これ誰が描いたかわからないんですけど
まあお寺っていうのは大体そういう伝統だから
みんなそうやってアジャンタであろうが
このトルファンとか中央アジアのね
洞窟とかね もうえらいもう芸術というかね
美術館みたいにね もう壁の一センチ四方も空いておかないんです
白い色では 何か描いておく
何か花やら何か描いておく
お釈迦様の命の語りやら
もう何かが で あるいは何か彫る
で それで贅沢って何でしょうかと
わからない とにかく若い坊主が生活するのはね
まあ仏教の生き方だからね
寝るところ贅沢全然ない
このインドの中央アジアにある洞窟ですよ
砂漠でしょうし 周りは
もうただのちょっと石を平らにして
そこらへん横になって寝るだけで
座るときでもちょっと石を座れるぐらい平ら
それはすごい もうものすごいシンプルで
もうそれ以上シンプルにできないというところまでシンプルです
で 壁にいたら一センチ四方でも残ってないんです
玄関の扉がもう全部もうドアであろうがドア枠であろう
とかもむっちゃもう微細にしてまずくってる
で そこでかなり明るく
まあいろいろということでも
まあ仏画しか描けませんですけどね
肉的なものは全然描けません
それは禁止しているしね
まあというわけでもうぴったりと仏画なんですが
これ花の模様が描いてあったんですね
そのお坊さんたちがそれにぴょんと立派な花の作品ですねとかね
あまり美しさにびっくりしてカッサパ尊者に言うんですね
先生の仏の天井画はね
大変立派です あという
あ というこの花の模様なんですけど
これはどういう あ ある？って言って
そこであ なるほど そうなるほどと言って
私はこちら十八年も住んでますけどね
君らのおかげで今日初めて見た
目があるという一言が付け加わったんです
目がある君らのおかげで初めて見たんだと
あのおじは褒める思った
あれは大手泣きなんです
一番厳しいお坊さんですからね
私は十八年住んでいたのに見てない
見てなかった だから自分には目がないと言ってるんです
お釈迦様はあんな弟子なんです
で 悟ってもない ただもう遊んで
なちうち修行も置いておいて
お寺見学したり ちょっと遊んだりしている
そうなんだよ 君たちは目があるんだからね
やっと私にも見ることできました
はい だから俗僧をとらないっていうことなんです
天女見てっていうのは
これ目に映るでしょうに
横になったりするとね
天女全く見えないっていうのはありえないでしょうに
でもそちら側の存在もやっぱり俗僧とちゃうと
あ 綺麗な花だ 誰の作品ですか？なんていい作品ですかとか
そういう風になるでしょう
そう全くならなかったんです
だからあの若いお坊さんたちへの説明はカッサパ尊者の頭に全くなかったんです
ただ見ただけ それから下から三
一 二 三 四行目の真ん中から
ヤトートゥンヘ・ヴィッカラ・インドリヤス・プッタ・ドゥーラ・ヴィハリッサタ
あの もしあなたがトゥンヘ
もしあとアナ トゥンヘ
あなた方は比丘たちよ
インドリヤス この六根に対して
プッタ・ドゥーラ ガードしてて
守って ヴィハリッサタ
生活するならば アタ その時
トゥンヘ・ヒティ あなた方に対しても
マーラ・ウパーピマ マーラという悪鬼ものが
ニッビッジェ 諦めて パッカミッサティ
出て行っちゃいますよ
あなた方はこのろ-ろ-六本のあの五神
五根をね 外へ出さないで
ちゃんとガードしておけば
マーラがずーっと待ってるんです
取ってやるぞと あなた方はこの眼耳鼻舌身意という六つを守るならば
マーラが待っていて 待っていて
待っていて で やがて諦めて出て行くんだと
オーターヤ・アラガマノ
隙間が見つからないで逃げていく
クンマ・マーガ・シヤーガ
あの 亀から えーと 狐が諦めて逃げていったように
逃げてはない 諦めて出て行ったように
君らからもマーラが出て行くんだと
それで安全でしょ だからいつまで守るかというと
だからこのマーガ どっ
いつまで 死ぬまでああいう風にこの畳んだままいるんですかね
自分のあの五体を これはいられないでしょう
やっぱり狐がいるうち
いっといて 狐がもうまあこれだったら餌食になりませんよと分かって出て行ったら
もうそこらへん餌を食べるなりね
川に戻るなりに だから心のこの問題をね
心でこの合成して煩悩を作る
心の中で怒りが生まれる
欲が生まれる 嫉妬 憎しみ
愚痴こみ あらゆる煩悩が生まれる
それを見ることで失敗する
聞くと失敗してるんですよ
失敗で捕まってるんです
もう煩悩からは逃げられません
例えば人の話を聞いて怒っても
その人は永久的に自分の前にいるわけないでしょう
だって二 三分で出ていくんですよ
怒ってる場合はあえて早く出ていくでしょうに
中見せている場合は 出ていくといったってに出ていかないでしょうに
だから怒ったらその人はもうあえて早く出ていくのに
こちらに生まれた煩悩はもう永久的にゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ湧いてきて
湧いてきて 湧いてきて
もう抜けられないんですね
だからこの経典でマーラっていうのは
悪魔っていうのはその働きなんです
だから私たちはマーラの支配下にいるんだと
マーラの帝国を破ってないんだと
だから目もマーラの領域で
耳もマーラの領域で どこからでも捕まっちゃう
マーラに捕らえたっていうことは
怒りやら欲やら憎しみやら生まれたことになる
もう食べられたと 本当に食べられるんだから我々食わされてるんだから
怒りに欲に煩悩に だから自分で生きてるんじゃないでしょうに
怒りのために生きている
欲のために生きている
憎しみのために生きている
だから我々よく言うでしょ
日本の仏教でも生かされているとかね
確かにその通りなんです
生きているわけじゃないんです
誰一人も 日本仏教は生かされていることをありがたい言葉として使ってますけど
それはまあ今私が使ってるのは逆に使ってるんです
その通りで生かされてるんだよ
誰も生きてないんだよ
怒りのままで 怒りの今まるで
欲の今まるで 憎しみの今まるで
落ち込みが生まれたら落ち込みが言うように生きてるんです
だから自分で生きている気持ちはしないんです
自分では外に出て楽しく仕事をしたいんだけど
やっぱりできない 怒りも落ち込みが命令して
あんたはそんなことするんじゃない
会社休めと 学校に行きたいんだけど
もう落ち込みが入ったんだから行くなよと
家に閉じ込まれていなさいと部屋で
それでだからもう引きこもりになってる子供は生きてる気がしますかね
本人にも自覚感でできない
だから生かされているってことはまさにその通りで
誰一人人間生きてない
生かされてるだけ 誰に生かされてるかというと
悪魔に生かされてるだけ
悪魔って何なのかというと
あらゆるすべての煩悩が悪魔なんです
それは外から入るかというと
全然そうではありません
ただ こちらのガードがまずいだけ
それですぐ六想 六想を取った瞬間にもう怒り系か欲系の感情が生まれて
それからもうみんな感情が生まれる
で 一応説明はそれで終わって
その説明はなんで入ったかというと
この下にある偈があるんですよ
ページで これはスッタニパータにもブッダの言葉というテキストにもあると思います
これが一番古い教えだと思います
その教えの説明なんです
クンモーアంగాニサテーカパーレ サモーダハン ビック マノーウィタクオー アニッスイトー アンニャ マヘーテヤーヌパリムットーノーカワディエキンシー
クンモーワアンガーニサテーカパーレ
サモーダハンビックマノーウィタックホー
アニッストーアンニャマヘーテヤンガーノー
パリムットーノーカワディエキンシー
クンモーワアンガーニサテーカパーレ
これ後ろから説明します
サテーカパーレ 自分の甲羅の中に
アンガーニ 五体を クンモー
えーと なんて言ったっけ
亀が サモーダハン 威厳と
収めるようにと ワっていうのはようにというですね
クンモーワ 亀のように
亀 がですけどね 亀が収めるように
日本語になってくると
ワ りえがサモーダハンのところに来ないとね
アンガーニ 自分の身部を
身部 体の身部を サテーカパーレ
自分の甲羅の中に サモーダハンが
あの 収めるように 亀が収めるように
ビッく ビクが マノーウィタックホー
マノーウィタックホーっていうのは心に生まれる概念
いわゆる妄想なんですね
心に生まれるあらゆる考え方なんですね
収めると 心の中に妄想が生まれないように
ちゃんと収めるように
だから私は瞑想を通してずっと言ってるのはそういうことなんです
妄想やめてみなさいと
瞑想の基本っていうのは考えないこと
それで問題は解決 考えないだけのこと
それにマノーウィタックホー
頭の中であれやこれやと考えること
それを収めなさいよと
アニッスと 何にも依存しないこと
依存するってのは 例えば花を見て
あ 桜の花だと言ったとたん
もう形相とってますね
それで花に依存することになる
あ 見なくちゃ それから
あ きれいだとか いろいろ感情が生まれてくる
だから あの 同じ話で あの
依存しないと言ったらなんか別な話に感じるんですけど
同じものなんです 音を聞いて
あ きれいな音楽だと思ったら
もう依存しているんです
知らないCDをやると
あれ なんかすごい いいじゃない
その音 音楽はと思ったら
もう依存 ガードしてないんですね
だから依存というのはこのガードの問題なんです
ガードしないともう依存しているんです
いわゆるクモの例では
クモが足でも出したら
もう出した瞬間にもう
キツネがもう噛んでるんですよ
もう依存でしょ もう逃げられない
次にアニナンアヘテヤーノ
アニナン 他人 他人を ヘーテーティっていうのは
まああの 害を与えることですね
アヘテヤーノっていうのは他人に何の害も与えない
無害者になる そこでヴィパッサナーの基本も全部入ってますよね
このちょっと四行の中に
怒りというの感情が生まれたら
やっぱり え 加害者になってしまうんですね
世界はいつでもね 戦うの論理でできてるでしょ
仏教は全く真反対 戦わないというところ
他人とは全然対立しない
マジリって言えばそこら辺はマジリでもあります
そういう人はパリムットー
パリムットーっていうのは
これ日本語にパレン 涅槃に入りますよと言っても
これはこの 落ちつきます
あの世には平安にあります
いわゆる山火事がずっと消えて静かになったっていう状態を説明してるんですね
我々は山火事のように
爆発してる火山のようにもえて恐ろしい状態にいる
それがすっと消えてしまって
静かになる 涼しくなる
心が それが涅槃ということなんです
パリムットーノーカワディエキンシー
誰 ウパーデーヤっていうのは文句言うこと
喧嘩することなんですね
その人は誰にも文句言ったり喧嘩したりすることなくなっちゃいますね
あんたが悪い あんたのせいやとかね
私はこんな目遭ったのはあんたのせいだとよく言うでしょ
それウパーデーヤっていう
違うでしょ あんた 自分のせいでしょうに
[笑い]だから他人のせいにしないことになるんだよね
だからこの四行の偈っていうのは
ものすごい膨大な意味を入っていて
仏道全部その四行で語ってるんです
だから四行だけでも十分ですよ
人間にとっては だから次の経典読んだって仏道全部語ってるんだから
また繰り返しになる 読経として読む人にとっては
真面目に勉強する人にとっては
修行する人にとってはこれだけでも十分です
ヴェーダッスもサトリも慈悲も全部言ってるんです
生き方も何一つも欠けることなく
だから純粋のブッダの生残りっていうのはそういう風なもの
すごいまとめてあって
またすごい実に単純な感じ
これがわからないってことは一つもないはずなんです
残っているのは まだ私たちは患者であること
もう治療法はじゅうぶんに目の前である
完治する治療法 残っているのは患者の仕事
薬を取って飲むことだけ
病気の説明と なぜ病気になったかと
これなぜこの薬で完治するかと
それは全部そちらで説明してあって
目の前に治療薬まで出しているんです
これで言うことないでしょう
だから自分で手を出して飲みなさいっていうぐらいでいいじゃない
そしたらお釈迦様はできます
ということで終了いたします
えーと では もし特にご質問等ないようでしたら
ちょっと早めですけど
今日はこれで終わりにしたいと思います
早めだったらその偈文をみんなちょっと習ってみてください
偈を 人間というのはこのくだらない歌ではなくてね
こういうものを口ずさんだり
歌ったり 楽譜 あの楽譜ってあるね
楽譜ですか 作って あのバイオリンでもギターでもね
弾きながらでもそういうのを歌うと
これは仏教徒たちじゃ楽しみにそれをやるんです
俗世間の楽しみはしない
どれだけ最近の人々は音楽を聞きたいし
演奏したいし 踊りたいし
もうしょうがないんだからね
その時はこういうものを歌にするんですね
で ミャンマーでもスリランカでも昔からみんな歌ったり踊ったりしましたよと
でも歌ったり踊ったりするとき使う歌は全部仏教なんです
汚いことはあまり言わない
欲を増えることっていうのは
だからこういうのはあの意味がものすごい膨大です
だからもういくらなんでもそれは自分なりに意訳することもできるわ
あと これ四行ではなくて
四行の意味は まあものすごいページぐらいに伸ばして
もう訳することもできるわ
そのその人の理解のレベルに合わせてね
いくらでもできるですね
ですから こういうものの
この簡単に唱えられるように口ずさめることは簡単にできるように習った方がいいんじゃないかなと
それからまあ では 一度一回私は言います
クンモーウェアンガーニサテーカパーレサモデハンディックマノビタンコ
アニッシトアニエマエテヤノ
パリニブトノペワディエキンシー
クンモワアンガニサテカパレ
サモデハンディックマノビタンコ
アニッシトアニエマエテヤノ
パリニブトノペワディエキンシー
クンモワアンガニサテカパレ
サモデハンディックマノビタンコ
アニッシトアニエマエテヤノ
パリニブトノペワディエキンシー
じゃあ皆さんもう一回聞いてください
復唱してください  クンモワアンガニサテカパレ
サモデハンディックマノビタンコ
アニッシトアニエマエテヤノ
パリニブトノペワディエキンシー
という風に自分なりの自分に響いてる節を入れた方がやりやすいんですけどね
いろいろもうそうやって言い方がある
それは自由自在でね お坊さんたちにしても
それぞれ自分なりの自分なりの言い方があるんです
だから別にその唱える歌う方法っていうのはないんでね
言葉ですから ですから
自分なりの節を入れて
はい もう一回言って終わりにしましょう
クンモワアンガニサテカパレ
サモデハンディックマノビタンコ
アニッシトアニエマエテヤノ
パリニブトノペワディエキンシー
じゃあそういうことで今日の話は終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます